it was a greatest blessing just being
vulnerable and honest with people about
how much I was struggling it made me
realize I hate being vulnerable I want
to be independent and do everything
myself I came out of the womb that way
but you got to lean on other people
sometimes and if you don't give them the
gift of being honest about how you're
struggling then they don't get the gift
I think of helping them hey hey and
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special I'm excited to welcome
shannon bream she's the author of the
brand new book finding the bright side
we'll get into that book and everything
else you need to know about shannon
bream in just one second but first
hiring is challenging which is why you
know we end up with people who have to
adjust the lights every single episode
but there's one place you can go where
hiring is simple and fast and smart it's
a place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates that place Zipp
recruiter comm slash ben and guests zip
recruiter sends your jobs over 100 of
the web's leading job boards they don't
just stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter will
actually scan thousands of resumes and
find people at the right experience and
then invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and then spotlights
the top candidates so you're never going
to miss a great match zipper query is so
effective
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter got a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash been
guest that's zip recruiter comm slash of
B and GU est zip recruiter comm slash
been guest zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire everybody here at
the office is on notice that if they do
a terrible job we're heading straight to
zip recruiter comm slash been guests
replace them you too can upgrade your
employees or get new employees who are
great go check them out at zip recruiter
comm slash been guest well Shannon
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it it's great to be with you
so when we start with this I'm not a
person who is particularly known for
finding the bright side you obviously
are somebody who's done that
how do you stay positive I mean it's you
have a difficult job and you're covering
the news every day you're doing it late
at night it's a very fraught political
cycle so how do you stay positive all
the time the way you seem to you know I
try to keep perspective sometimes you
have to compartmentalize things and we
do report on things that are really
tough especially if it's you know a
situation with a loss of life it can be
natural disasters you know terrorist
attack whatever it is you have to do
what you have to do in the
report these things but for me I try to
separate that and have my real life
where have a little bit of perspective
on the bigger picture for me my faith is
at the center of everything and that's
really my compass and kind of where I
have my foundation and so for a lot of
people I think I'm not sure where they
put their roots and where they kind of
find that stability but that's it for me
so one of the big controversies broken
out in sort of the journalistic sphere
is the objective journalist versus
opinion journalist divided now I'm very
obviously an opinion journalist I say
what I what I think it must be difficult
for you because you are a fair and
balanced objective journalist that means
you're trying to remove your views how
do you how do you number one do that
this is a human being and number two how
much do you think it's possible to do
that as a journalist I think you have to
make the effort 100 percent of the time
if you're in as I am in the news
division and we got through our show
every night when we're preparing it we
want to make sure that all sides are
presented do we have guests that are
opposing in views on any particular
issue we're going to cover we go through
the copy very carefully and say let's
take out any adjectives that are over
the top it's always good to winnow those
out and just let the story speak for
itself let the facts speak for
themselves we make sure that we give
voices to all sides it doesn't matter
what I agree or disagree with and I feel
like I'm doing my job if at the end of
the day my Twitter is split I have some
people on there who say like you're the
worst you are attacking our president
why don't you respect him and on the
other side the very same show I have
people who will say obviously you're
taking all of your talking points
straight from the White House the
president told you exactly what to say
and I think well if people don't know
where I'm coming from personally then
I've done my job because of course all
of us have our own opinions as human
beings but I my goal every night in
doing the show is that people don't know
what my personal opinions are we just
give them the news our viewers are smart
they can figure things out for
themselves so we give them the
information and leave it to them so is
it frustrating for you you see a lot of
politicians particularly the Democratic
side of the aisle now having this open
debate about whether it's even
appropriate to do things like appear on
Fox News whether to do these town hall
events with the objective side of Fox
News people like Bret Baier and then you
have senator Elizabeth Warren who goes
on the view and says well Fox News hate
machine and a propaganda machine I'll
never appear on there and even their
objective hosts are just providing cover
for their non objective hosts what do
you make of that critique of Fox I
expect it I mean it's something that if
you work there for five minutes you know
you're going to have to deal with I
always encourage people and sometimes I
think I get a convert or two out there
who will say Oh
how could you work there at such a
terrible place especially as a woman and
you know they go through the whole
litany of problems and I say make me a
deal will you watch our 11 o'clock show
or 6 o'clock with bread we're 7 o'clock
with Martha or any of our shows that are
strictly news programs watch it for a
week or two and then see what you think
you don't have to watch the
opinion-based shows which we celebrate
they have their own fan base and they
spark really interesting conversations
but for the news division I say watch
one of our shows that is straight down
the middle and then you tell me what you
think and I find that most of our
critics have not spent any time doing
that so I think it's fair to ask them to
recognize the difference choose one of
those news programs and then you can
judge for yourself and I think if people
do that they might be pleasantly
surprised how much does the news
division interact with the opinion
division do you guys talk amongst
yourselves are you guys friends how does
that work we are all friends I mean my
hallway I've got Tucker or Laura Bret
and myself we're all in there and Brit
Hume is on her hallway too and we will
pop in we're all friends we'll exchange
ideas and talk about things and news of
the day of course what are you gonna do
on your show who have you got on tonight
that kind of thing
but when it comes to putting our shows
together making editorial decisions
there's really no crossover at all I
mean we're friendly with each other but
we have completely different production
staffs and the way that we tackle our
shows I think is very different so given
sort of the the politically fraught
nature of the moment and the very strong
opinions that people hold about
President Trump what do you think is the
best way as an objective journalist to
cover President Trump it's been kind of
fascinating from the left there's been a
contention that if you treat anything
that is pro Trump with any level of
seriousness that you are somehow
contributing to his fake news narrative
or that you are somehow covering for him
on the right there's this feeling that
if you criticize President Trump at all
then you are being disloyal or that
you're or that you're treating him as
something terrible what what is the best
way to cover President Trump and how
exactly do you separate the narrative
from the from the news when you do this
I think that we stick to the facts I
think that's the most important thing
and if he has a good day he makes a good
decision something's good with the
economy I mean we just report it down
the middle and some people will see even
that as taking a side they as you said
there's some people who say you
shouldn't even treat him as a legitimate
president if you cover him in that way
in some way you are legitimizing
something that they feel is illegitimate
but I think you know he tweets we don't
cover every single tweet but if they're
newsworthy we do and sometimes he makes
policy statements by tweet we try to win
oath
but again if it's factual information
its data from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics on unemployment those kinds
of things that's what we traffic in in
the news side that's what we do in our
particular hour and I find that so much
of people's reaction is projection
either they're Pro President Trump
they're anti President Trump and I think
that their feelings factor into the way
that they hear what we're saying so we
try to be very careful in the way that
we present things knowing that people
are gonna come at it from you know often
very tribal places and it's sometimes we
have to remind ourselves more about
their emotions and things are so
emotional and passionate on both sides
right now it's more about that than it
is about what we're presenting so what
do you make of the critique that the
Trump administration is somehow uniquely
stonewalling that they they're I mean
you're journalists the critique is that
they are a threat to press freedom you
have Jim Acosta and ladies find you
someone who loves you like Jim Acosta
webstream Acosta but you have Jim Acosta
at CNN who actually puts out books about
how victimized he is from an
air-conditioned office in Washington DC
so as a journalist what's your
impression of how transparent the Trump
administration is or is not I think if
anything I would say that this
administration sometimes there are
members of one who feel like they're too
transparent because he does say and
think what he you know he he hey he puts
it all out there whether it's on Twitter
whether it's stopping to talk at these
gaggles as he does so often when he
comes to or from the White House I mean
that's something we didn't always get
with previous administrations he will
stop and take question after question
and I think in the beginning there were
probably some people on the staff we're
like no no let's keep it moving just get
on Murray one and let's go on this trip
he loves that he loves to engage there
but I think his critics are gonna say
yeah he's been really nasty to the press
the fact that he points them out or
calls them out when they're at these
rallies he always points to them in the
back it's something you see him
consistently do he knows it's a winning
talking point for him with a crowd who's
there
but as far as transparency is concerned
I think he's made himself in ways that
are very unique to him much more
available to the press into these
questions then a lot of people have in
the past because even if he's doing a
joint presser with a foreign leader he
ends up taking all kinds of questions
that I think sometimes people in his
staff were trying to manage him would
like him to do less of that but I think
he's made himself pretty available I
think every White House is gonna be
criticised for not turning over more
documents or having more press
conferences because they are limited in
that purse
we don't have a ton of press conferences
and briefings from them that we've had
more of those in the past so I think he
gives you a little bit more on the
personal side but I think on the more
structured side of the way that this
administration talks to people certainly
there are those in the press you wish
and more of that and one of the things
that's been kind of fascinating is to
watch the dynamic dynamic between
President Trump and Fox News so he'll
tweet things out where it's as though he
has certain expectations that Fox News
is going to cover him in a particular
way again making I think some of the
same mistakes that people on the left
make mistaking the opinion stuff the
sean hannity show for for your show for
example or the idea that if fox news has
a town-hall with pete Budaj edge and
this is somehow fox news now supporting
people to judgment before they were just
the Trump Network and and that seems to
have created a false perception of Fox
News among people right and left so in
your mind what do you think Fox News
actually is cuz obviously it's a huge
talking forum for people on both sides
of the aisle what I think's interesting
about Fox and I always tell the story
but my dad's birthday is the same day
that Fox launched and he loved that
because he is you know as a former law
enforcement officer he's passed away now
he was a former Marine everybody says
never former but I just mean in that
he's not in this earth anymore to say
hoorah
but he felt like when Fox launched it
actually was a place that presented
stories and viewpoints that he felt
represented for the first time in a long
time in the media not that they were
taking his side but at least that they
told his part of the story or that they
looked at stories that other people
would overlook the fact that it was
being presented so I think about a lot
of people like my parents and people out
there in America feel like okay this is
a place that's at least going to treat
our viewpoint like it's one worthy of
conversation or being included so I
think Fox is unique in some of the
stories that we pick and the way that we
do things there's definitely the opinion
contingent which is highly popular and
has a very devoted fan base but we do
make a real effort to keep a dividing
line between that and the news division
so I think in the news division we do
stories that you may not hear other
places and we tackle stories in a
different way but our commitment is
always to have both sides on I don't
think it's interesting to go on and have
you know any kind of conversation about
a particular issue whether it's abortion
or taxation or whatever it is and only
have one side I think it's a much more
interesting conversation for people to
make sure you have two or three sides or
however many you can fit into a
broadcast
to have that conversation kiss me that's
adding value that's where our viewers
can learn something new maybe or at
least feel like hmm okay I hadn't
thought about that particular point I'm
willing to at least hear it so let's
talk a little bit about your sort of
back story so how you got where you are
because yeah there's a lot of this in
your book finding the bright side so if
you if you go back all the way to the
beginning you grew up in a very
Christian household that had very solid
values obviously you talked at the
beginning of the book for few chapters
about your mom and how she really
impacted oh if I was hoping we could
talk a little bit about that yeah I talk
about the chapter about her is called
the meanest mom in the world and people
cringe sort of when I say that but the
truth is she embraced that title there
was actually a yardsale that she went to
which is the kind of thing we would have
done growing up that there was a plaque
there called meanest mom in the world
she actually found it when the book came
out and tweeted and texted me a picture
of it because it does exist and it's
hilarious cuz it talks about sort of
like I'm not your friend we will be one
day but right now I'm here to keep you
on the straight and narrow and keep you
out of trouble my word goes and that's
it kind of thing
she hung that up in the kitchen and that
really is how I grew up I mean I really
was not allowed to listen to secular
music there was definitely no don't
dancing and that kind of thing there was
a ton of love though and I understood
the discipline because I was from a
young age always asking why why why
don't we do it this way my idea is
better and my currents allowed me to do
that but they tried to channel that
energy and positive ways and kind of
keep me on the straight and narrow and
you know the little things that I did
here and there they got me into trouble
they always knew they always found it my
mom was a teacher at the school I went
to K through 12 so it was hard to get
away with really anything and I joke
about when the movie Footloose came out
I was in high school was not allowed to
see it because I was living in Footloose
somebody got a VHS copy people have to
google that and we watched it at
someone's house in their VCR and I
remember I didn't tell my parents I was
living it so that's really how I grew up
and you you really did lead an
extraordinarily clean life I mean for
somebody who's in in sort of public life
this is considered taboo now and as a
person who you know was religious also
from youth who is an outspoken virgin
until marriage as somebody who believes
in those sort of social standards it's
unique to read a book where somebody
talks about all those same sorts of
values went to Liberty University your
somebody took your faith seriously you
also talked about how when you were in
college you originally started not at
Liberty University he took some classes
over it was in Florida State and you
talk a little bit about maybe you know
what that clash of values was like it
was interesting I grew up in Tallahassee
so I had a full ride to Florida State
academically and it made sense to stay
home and be in Florida and be close to
my family and go to college basically
for free but my parents were very open
listen if you want to go to a place like
Liberty where you're going to get an
education but you're also going to have
people investing in her faith and
allowing you to grow in that the whole
time were open to that - even though I
knew financially I'd be tougher for them
for me to do that so I did take classes
right out of high school at Florida
State it's a great University but I
realized that very first class that I
had in psychology that there were gonna
be serious questions about my faith we
were asked to write about the most
important thing in our lives and I
talked about my relationship with God
and I had a professor who wasn't nasty
about it but was sort of patronizing
like you'll get over that at some point
like this is not legit and I remember
thinking I'm 17 I'm going off into the
world is this what I want to do for the
next four years or do I want to have
another four years of kind of really
rooting myself in my faith and Liberty
has very interesting classes that are
required for everybody to take that or
kind of apologetics classes and really
questioning and and digging into the
doubts about your faith and learning the
other side of the argument and I thought
I think I'll do four more years of that
before I get into the world that's going
to constantly be questioning the most
important thing in my life one of the
things that I found interesting the book
and I found this to be a common thread
you know for a lot of the folks that I
interview who are very successful is
that you were bullied and not treated
great back when you were in high school
and now it's funny because whenever you
see people who are super successful and
they say well I was bullied back in high
school people tend to think no that's
not right especially somebody like you
you were you know enemies you're the
winner of the Miss USA pageant hey how
are you bullied in high school how's
that even a possibility what was it like
to people how do you think that shaped
you as a person um I will say I had a
really great environment in that it was
a high school where had a lot of friends
I was always sort of on the fringe I
felt like I wasn't cool I was sort of a
nerd partially because my mom was
omnipresent at everything that I was
ever trying to do and giving out
detentions and stuff to the cool kids in
school so there were times when it was
hard to try to be cool at all I was a
voracious reader so I had you know these
thick glasses I was one of those little
kids I'm not sure it was cute but like
second third grade wearing glasses
always had a book in my hand I was a
bookworm and I eyed Joe but really I
think
only reason I had any friends is because
we had a pool so people would want to
come to our house to hang out of the
fool and I might have been in my room
reading books but there they're having a
great time jumping around in pool so I
just and I still I think carry this
which i think is a good thing to feel
like you're always sort of on the
outside a little bit looking in and I
felt that way as a kid and and I
certainly was not cool there was a very
cool girl who and it have been great
friend of mine who lived across the
street from me she's a little bit older
didn't have any of the rules that I had
and I thought she was super cool because
she listened to all you know these hair
bands and they had cable at their house
I mean all these things we never would
have had but I remember she used to make
fun of me for just how sheltered she
thought I was and uncool that I was but
I think it makes you get a little bit of
a shell and almost a badge of yeah I
don't have to cave in to peer pressure I
joke in the book I didn't have a ton of
peers pressuring me to do any savings
but I wasn't afraid to kind of be my own
person and stand up and kind of be a
little bit of an outsider and I still
kind of on the inside I think always
feel that way so in a second I'm gonna
ask you about how you got from doing
stuff at Liberty University and going on
trips to Brazil to do humanitarian aid
to doing beauty pageants gonna get to
that in just one second first
as summer sizzles do you feel like you
are cooking in your clothes like
roasting if you can't handle the heat
it's probably because you need new
underwear and Tommy John has the perfect
solution Tommy John's innovative cool
cotton underwear for men and women it's
a summer must-have it's like your own on
body air-conditioner which you need if
you live out in California Tommy John's
cool cotton fabric features breathable
lightweight fibers that keep you two to
three times cooler and drive four to
five times faster than regular cotton
Tommy John men's and women's underwear
supported no wedgie guarantee that
totally would have helped me back in
high school all their underwear comes in
a range of styles and fabrics that are
suited to your entire summer wardrobe
the legs never ride up the waist bands
never roll down they're unique design
ensures there's no pinching or bunching
ever Tommy John is so sure you're gonna
love the fit and feel it's all backed by
their best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free guarantee that means if you don't
love that first pair you get a full
refund Tommy John no adjustment needed
hurry over to Tommy John comm / Ben
right now to get 20% off your first
order that is Tommy John comm / Ben for
20% off Tommy John comm / Ben how do I
know they're good because I'm wearing
them right now Tommy John comm / button
alright so let's talk about your history
in in beauty pageant thing so this I
will admit this is not as happy and
think about so maybe you can explain
sort of the appeal of it like well what
got you into this in the first place
yeah when I was a little kid I'd watched
Miss America with my mom and my grandma
and I thought it was so glamorous and I
thought how do these people have it so
together you know these sparkly evening
gowns they look perfect they know
everything about solving world peace
they have all these great ideas I just
like these are like otherworldly beings
I think this is really exciting and as I
got older I learned a lot more about the
Miss America pageant than it actually
most of the winnings that you would have
are paid in scholarship were you
actually then if you have scholarship
money you have to submit to them you
know your tuition bills and that kind of
thing and it's very much pushed toward
getting you to finish your education and
get scholarship in the process so for me
I had a guy who cut my hair I talked
about him in the book who was running
one of these local pageants that fed
into Miss America and I'd done one
before it was disastrous because during
the talent competition I forgot my piano
piece halfway through but total stage
fright I thought maybe this pattern
thing isn't for me but the guy who come
here is like no no you should do this
again you should try it and I went on to
win this little local pageant I go off
to miss Virginia still with this
horrible stage fright about playing the
piano and it really deepened my prayer
life I say to people because I was so
terrified and praying the whole time
onto the stage through the piece you
know getting through it and just saying
like God I know that you've brought me
here for a reason and I have to depend
on you in this terrifying situation
which I think a lot of things in life if
they scare you it's kind of a good idea
to try it and that's kind of how I
viewed this whole thing and a few months
later I was there in the finals of Miss
America never thinking as a 19 year old
I was gonna go from you know almost
falling off the stage with embarrassment
and forgetting my piece to being in the
finals of Miss America but it's like
unlike anything I ever did before it
enabled me to graduate from college with
zero debt which was a huge gift to my
family because I come from a modest
background but it forced me to go out
and travel on my own speak really dig
into a lot of ideas the very first
question I got at Miss America was there
was a KKK rally in Georgia yesterday is
that really what the First Amendment
you know protects and I thought whoa
okay we're gonna have serious questions
and serious discussion and so it's a
very thoughtful engaging process not for
everyone not everyone wants to walk
onstage in a swimsuit and high heels but
that was actually the least of my
worries there the whole rest of the
process was much more terrifying to me
than walking around there's been a lot
of criticism of the pageant
specifically because of the sort of
swimsuit aspect of it from both sort of
feminists right feminists left and also
from the social Conroy people saying
well basically isn't that just skimpy
attire is that appropriate what's your
take on whether these pageants should
continue to include things like swimsuit
competitions
I mean to me it's nobody is forcing you
to do this if you choose this way
potentially to put yourself through
school or to you know push yourself
intellectually to really dig into these
issues for a lot of the young women
that's the toughest part is doing the
interview and having to dig into
questions like the First Amendment or
gun control or whatever it is there are
a lot of political questions in the
pageant now so I think that there are a
lot of ways to look at how it pushes you
I mean from me the physical aspect of it
was the least of it it did encourage me
to quit being a lazy college student in
eating 24/7 and be much more disciplined
in that part of my life so it was
disciplined across the board not for
everyone I mean for me it was you know a
great option but I know a lot of the
programs are trying to and Miss America
especially are trying to modernize in
that they're saying if you do swimsuit
you could wear active wear if you want
to and we're not gonna insist that
everybody be a skeleton I mean it's it's
about who you are and what your body is
and I think it's been healthy that
there's been much more acceptance in
advertising or the patents or whatever
that people are unique and they have
different shape and you know you could
be positive about whoever you are for me
it took me to a different level of
discipline across the board that I
needed as a college kid do you think
that when it comes to pageant thing that
they're serious questions to be asked
about objectification of women people
treating women simply is sort of pretty
objects yes there's this there's all of
this other aspect there's playing music
and people answering political questions
but the essence of it is it is a beauty
contest it is not just a piano playing
contest isn't Tchaikovsky Competition in
Russia yeah done well with that so what
do you make up of that particular
criticism I get it I mean I completely
get it and I understand that we're
having important conversations about the
role of women and the role of equality
and all of those kinds of things so for
me if it's not for you fantastic
I'm not gonna play in the NFL I mean
there are different options for
different people I say we don't take it
away and say this option is no longer
going to be there because for some young
women it's you know a lot of fun it's
very helpful financially and it's and
it's a good option for some people but I
get that some people will say
listen if you're walking out on the
stage and a swimsuit that's not great
for women but do you take that decision
away then from women who say no for me
it's fun
I don't feel pressure and I enjoy doing
it I think in the 21st century we can
have all the options on the table if
it's not for you don't do it I mean it
is pretty interesting to see this sort
of uniting between as I say the social
right and sort of the feminist left a
lot of these issues at the same time
there's this this move that's been very
bizarre in in both media and advertising
away from basic human standards of
beauty meaning the idea is that we're
supposed to pretend that a beauty
pageant is no longer a beauty pageant
that basically it is the Tchaikovsky
Competition and the only way for this
stuff to survive is for us to move away
from the very idea of a beauty pageant
at all seems to me that if you're gonna
do a beauty pageant it seems like you
should probably be part of it yeah and I
think you see that now there's a
difference in Miss America Miss USA a
lot of people you know you hear one and
it sounds the same they actually split
years ago over an issue related to
swimsuits so Miss Americas is seen as
the more academic you have the
scholarship fund Miss USA does not
apologize I mean they do swimsuit
evening gown and an interview portion
they're all equal and they don't shy
away from it and for a lot of young
women who are smiling aspiring models
actresses the woman who just won Miss
USA is a lawyer I mean she's actually
been through school educated and is a
practicing lawyer so I think it's an
avenue for different people to choose
what they want to pursue you Miss USA
makes no bones about the fact that this
is a beauty pageant this is a
competition but we also have women here
who are doctors and lawyers and if
that's what they choose to do good for
them yeah I mean when I was at Harvard
Law one of my friends that was actually
a former Miss America winner Erica
Harold who ended up working for Congress
in Illinois and they're an enormous
number of qualified women who actually
compete in this sort of stuff and are
really academically brilliant so
speaking of that you you ended up moving
on into into law so how did you decide
that that was the direction they wanted
to move well I was always fascinated by
politics and I you know it's all
intertwined with this idea of our laws
and how they come to be and how we
decide to navigate our society
my dad had always said to me when I was
in school you're going to law school or
med school you're gonna pick one I don't
hear anything about any guys or they
were sort of like you'd pick one of
those I didn't listen med school was not
ever gonna happen for me
from numerous reasons but law school had
no math and I thought that would be a
good option for me
I wasn't sure what I would do with it I
was very hesitant I thought I want to go
into law school I think it'll be a basis
for a lot of potential things I don't
know if I'll practice which I did
briefly but I had an opportunity to go
back home to Florida State in
Tallahassee and to go to school
basically again for free get a law
degree and then figure out what I was
gonna do but I even before I was out of
school I knew this is not going to be
the traditional practice of law isn't
what I was going to do the rest of my
life and so you ended up moving into TV
there there are tons of people who
actually obviously want to be in TV and
I'm sure the question they're all asking
is how do I do this what is the pathway
to getting into TV I'm sure their
enormous number of people who want a job
just like yours or your job how did you
get into TV I am honest with people I
mean I went to the bottom of the wrong
and started there I mean I wanted to go
do an internship I wanted to volunteer
at one of the local stations in Tampa
where I was practicing law in Florida
they said you can only come in as an
intern and I said okay well how do I do
that it's gotta be for college credit I
started calling all of the local
universities and schools like hey can I
take this credit through you so I can go
intern at this nope you have to come
back here get your mass comm degree when
you get into your third or fourth level
of classes then we'll approve this
internship credit and then you can do it
and I thought that's not realistic for
me right now so I just kept going no no
no no I finally get to University of
South Florida I get to the Dean of the
communication school I'm this is a time
when faxes are still happening I mean
I'm faxing my transcripts from law
school from college to say look I'm a
serious person I want to do this will
you help me he was the first person who
said okay you're driving me crazy
because I think if you just wear people
down that's half of it he said stop
faxing me and sending me all this stuff
I'll do this for you you have to do a
news writing class because you know
nothing about that will do that but then
I'll also approve the credits for you to
go intern at night at the station so I
did that and I didn't tell my law firm
and I would go nights and weekends
overnights whatever I had to do to just
go intern there I would go out with
photographers reporters I would work the
desk
answer the phone make coffee I mean I
started at the bottom I was running
everybody's errands while practicing law
during the day but I loved it I'd love
to be in the newsroom and I thought you
know I need to stick with us and figure
out what to do here so few months into
it when the internship was wrapping up I
went to the boss there and said I'm
gonna quit my law firm and he was like
uh no one here has offered you a job my
fatality I feel like this is what I'm
gonna do so I'm just gonna you know move
down this path and within a few weeks
there they had
this overnight position opened up 2 a.m.
to 11 a.m. and I took it and it was you
know a major salary cut the hours were
terrible I felt like I never saw my
friends my husband would tell you I was
tired all the time but so happy and so I
started at the bottom and I just any
little job they would let me take on I
learned TV production from being there
and doing and I was working the prompter
a producer quit I started producing I
mean it was just one thing after another
and just learning on the job which is a
you know sink or swim kind of situation
but it was a great experience yeah I
mean that that's a very familiar story I
finished law school I worked at a law
firm for ten months I hated it I
despised about it I was about to get
married we had just gotten a mortgage on
a condo and my wife looks at me and said
you should quit so I quit and I took the
job for one-third the pay right doing
production behind the scenes and that's
how everybody starts I mean then it's
still good to go to law school I mean I
definitely recommend folks should
continue it teaches you a certain way of
thinking that's very useful but don't
stick with something the aged right
because there's money behind it life is
too short
yeah and I had to tell myself even
within the news business there been
times I've taken promotions or different
jobs that were tied to a financial bump
and I thought I knew that wasn't right
for me but I did it for the wrong
reasons so I do think you have to follow
your passion and what you're gonna be
excited to get up every day and do so
how did you get from local news all the
way to Fox News being a national
broadcaster well I do like to include
the story about getting fired for my
very first DB job because the guy who
put me on TV left the station the new
guy who came in everybody was freaked
out and they say you don't understand
when a new person comes in they clean
house and I'm like I'm making no money
and I'm doing 10 jobs here and loving it
I have a great attitude like I'm safe no
you're not safe when I got called in and
the head of HR was sitting there I
literally for a second thought they're
promoting me no the head of HR sitting
there does not happening and the guy
said to me you're the worst person I've
ever seen on TV you will never make it
in this business
I don't know why anyone put you on
television it was humiliating and I
cried I literally went into a soundproof
out of bed and cried it was so
humiliated it took months and months and
months for me to get anyone to return my
calls I applied for jobs all over the
country eventually I landed at a
wonderful station in Charlotte North
Carolina worked there three years then
went to DC to work for the NBC affiliate
while I was there I if Fox had exploded
and I was sending my work there couldn't
get an interview
nobody cared because they get a thousand
resumes a day and so my husband
who handles professional speakers had
booked Brit Hume for an event it was a
Berta it was a breakfast event and he
said you need to come with me tomorrow
morning he'll be there maybe we can talk
to him I'd worked the late news the
night before I did not want to do it I
got up that morning had a huge zit on my
face like this is not a good first
impression I don't want to go my husband
convinces me to go so we get there
Brits wait waiting backstage in the
green room so he's sort of a captive
audience the programmes are running
behind a little ways into that my
husband says you may not know Brit my my
if you recognise my wife she is a local
anchor here in DC and Brits like all
very nice what would you like to do long
term and this was my moment of truth and
I just said I want to come work for you
at Fox and he was like that's nice he's
like people say that to me all the time
I'm not sure they understand exactly
what we do Howard son but send your
stuff over and maybe I can give you some
advice and career advice I'm a little
embarrassed I leave the room sort of
take a walk the guys were there talking
while I'm gone he says to Sheldon my
husband do you think that uh does she
like politics what does she like to
cover and he said well when she was in
law school she worked in the Florida
speaker's office and he said Law School
did she finish my husband's like yeah
she graduated with honors Brit says damn
do you think she would want to cover the
Supreme Court for Fox News and sort of
like I don't speak for her but I think
that would probably be a yes so I come
back in the room five ten minutes later
and Brit literally says to me when can
you start and I'm like I don't know what
just happened in here for the past five
minutes but I should be paying my
husband the agency fee that we're paying
to my agent and from there it was you
know there were several months in there
I was still in her contract with NBC
that where I'm trying to work things out
to get to Fox didn't think it was gonna
happen numerous times that looked like
it wouldn't come together and I had just
sort of let go of the process and
eventually when my contract was up with
NBC I went over to Fox thanks to Brit
Hume and I've been there scent ever
since so I want to ask you about the
Supreme Court beat what that was like
just one second but first with the ever
increasing number of car makes and
models it's now impossible to stock all
the parts you need in a traditional
chain store front
why injure often pointless or seemingly
intimidating questioning like is your
Odyssey and LX or an e^x
and wait while the counterman orders the
parts on his computer choosing the only
brand his warehouse happens to carry
this seems like a bad deal especially
because you have computers with access
to Rock Auto calm at home and in your
pocket Rock Auto calm is a family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years go to rock
Oh calm to shop for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or daily driver get everything
you need and a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it is
super easy to navigate quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
Rock Auto calm are always reliably low
and the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need go to rock Auto calm
but Rock auto calm right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
Shapiro's in there how did you hear
about us box so they know we sent you
because that's how you heard about them
so write shapiro and that how did you
hear about us box at Rock Auto calm so
let's talk about what it was like to
cover the supreme court obviously the
supreme court has become an incredible
hot button certainly over the course of
my life so I really think it's been
exacerbated over the really since Roe
vs. Wade but even in the last 15 or 20
years it seems to become the number one
issue in a lot of people's radar many
people attribute president Forbes
victory to the fact that there was an
open Supreme Court seat and that was
Scalia's seat so what was it like to
cover the Supreme Court how political
was it at the time when I first got
started I realized how much I had to
learn the very first giant case I
covered over there was dealing with
Guantanamo Bay the rights of various
prisoners there it had been back and
forth through the federal court system
numerous times and I just tried to read
the record and get ready for covering it
there at the Supreme Court I was like
whoa and this is a whole different level
of reporting
it's a tough beat to cover because there
are almost zero leaks over there I mean
anyone who's clerking there and they're
not gonna blow up their entire legal
career giving you information it's not
like Congress where people are like here
I've got stuff I want you to talk about
that I want to leave to you it's
completely the opposite but I loved it
because it was an intellectual challenge
for me I was getting to use that law
background doing it I just knew I had a
lot of work to do to get up to speed
over there so it was a little
overwhelming in the beginning it's a
very austere place and they don't mess
around over there but I've really
enjoyed getting to know the various
justices as much as you can really
trying to figure out how their brains
work how you think they're gonna vote
and really interpreting the oral
arguments because there are a lot of
them that labor eat raps on both sides
and they want to play devil's advocate
so you don't know how they're gonna vote
so yeah I mean it has become highly
political which I don't think is what
the founders ever intended for the
digital judicial branch at all I think
it's morphed into something that's
probably away from the original
intentions but covering the confirmation
hearings I should say battles over the
last several years I've never seen
anything like what happened with the
Cavanaugh situation I mean I've covered
that's probably my fifth one there was
nothing ever like that before and I
think even just you know you think about
- you know Justice Kennedy who was you
know such at the end you know the swing
vote he hated that term he was confirmed
97 to nothing I mean those days are gone
I can't imagine us doing that and years
ago they would confirm by voice vote now
it's a totally different process and I
think the whole thing has been so
politicized I think it's a little bit
off off the rails what do you think of
how the Cavanaugh hearings broke down
you and obviously that that was probably
the biggest hot-button issue of the last
five to ten years in American politics
maybe even surpassing the 2016 election
itself how do you think that that ended
up playing out yeah I mean I truly have
never seen anything like that because it
was there in the room and it became
apparent within 10 seconds of then
chairman Grassley starting the hearing
it was not going to be a normal hearing
at all
whether it was from the diet's from the
various members or the audience and
those seats for the public that I mean
we literally from our vantage point that
we're at as we're broadcasting sort of
in skybox is overlooking the area we
could look down and we'd see each group
that they brought in and you could
immediately we started playing sort of
bingo on the protesters like that one's
gonna pop up that one's gonna pop up it
was and I mean the first day it was so
jarring because it happened so often by
day three we were sort of like here's
another protestor Capitol police very
good with informing people if you do
this here's what's gonna happen quickly
quickly taking them out and moving on
with the hearings but then when we
started to get the fallout from the
letter that came in with senator
Feinstein revealing it all of that that
played out over the next few weeks it
just got so vitriolic there were times
that people did not feel safe I'm
talking about senators trying to get to
the floor to vote you saw it happen I
mean regardless of what side they were
on there were a lot of people who were
very upset I've never seen people that
emotional about anything I've covered
that's certainly the most emotional
topic or story that I've seen where
people just were relentless about it I
mean it
has become really bloodsport and and it
must be difficult for you I mean you're
a woman at Fox News which means that
you're going to be sure acted by the
media for having the temerity to be a
woman at Fox News what is that like I
mean now that it seems like every issue
is being broken down into a certain sort
of sexual politics where women are
expected to be on one side and men are
expected to be on another and Cavanagh
is an example of this where it must have
been that if you're a woman and you
thought that there were holes in
christine Blasi ford story then you are
being disloyal to women even if you
objectively covered that you were being
disloyal to women how did that how do
you deal with that well it's tricky
because as a woman who has had a few me
to moments myself in my life my legal
career and beyond but also being a
lawyer I thought we've got to be really
careful about this because I am a
hundred percent in favor as every
American I think should be in the idea
of due process no one in this country
should be accused without the
opportunity to defend themselves and to
have some due process this was different
because it's not a court proceeding you
know people would say it's the most
glorified job interview in the world so
I definitely had very serious concerns
about due process but as a woman who has
been through some of these things I
thought we need to hear from this person
and we need to allow senators to make
informed decision about who she is and
where she's coming from but as we
started to get in that second and third
and fourth tier of people who are now
sending in anonymous letters that he and
his friend had sexually assaulted them
multiple times in a car but I can't name
myself the guy who got in trouble for
sending in a false report about
something saying that a woman was on a
boat with Kavanagh and she called him
for help I mean it just got to be
preposterous we're like now we're losing
sight of the core story the person who
is willing to come here under oath and
tell her story his side of the story as
we're now you know Michael avenatti gets
into it we have the Julie sweat Nix I
mean it turned into such a circus that I
think people lost the ability to be
objective about a lot of it because it
became completely political and not
about the substance of what was being
discussed so I want to ask you about
some of those me to experiences so
obviously this has become a hot button
issue again in the country it seems like
this is really ratcheted up since 2012
when Mitt Romney was about the most
anodyne human being ever to walk the
earth was supposedly waging a war on
woman and then that was revived
obviously during 2016 when President
Trump was not anodyne was running for
president of the United States and
Hillary Clinton sort of revived that
so you've been in the TV industry which
is not well known for its treatment a
good treatment of women you were in
beauty pageants also not typically well
known for wonderful treatment of women
what were some of what's your
perspective on meet you and what were
some of kind of the experiences that
you've had well I mean there's some you
know there's the funny subtle stuff that
is not a sexual assault but it makes you
very aware of some gender stereotypes
and things I can remember as a young
attorney that I was conducting a
deposition and the person came in that
day with her lawyer I met them out front
and they said tell mr. Brean that I'm
here and please get me some coffee you
know I
it's mrs. bream and I'll see about
getting you some coffee those subtle
things and probably most of that had to
do with the fact that I was so young and
baby-faced as a new attorney like I'm
gonna be the one to posing you today
there were times that we would show up
for a deposition for something else and
there's somebody there that maybe we
were representing the company that they
worked for and they were being accused
of sexual harassment the way that they
treated me when I walked in the door I
thought might be true you might want to
settle this case I made sure just that
stuff that happens like Thanks this may
not be your best character witness here
but there were you know there were times
over the years where I've been put in
situations that were uncomfortable there
were discussions about my body or about
being more sexual or being more sexy on
TV I mean those conversations are
uncomfortable and you have to navigate
them carefully as a woman I'd been a
sexual harassment attorney when I was
sitting in those conversations and I'm
thinking okay there are lines I'm not
gonna cross how close am I to that line
because my career does matter to me I
think there's a way to as a woman
navigate this carefully to respectfully
use comedy or humor to get myself out of
this situation not offending the person
who's now making a decision about my
career but also maintaining my own
dignity and sometimes it's a it's a
really thin line to walk yeah how do you
decide where exactly that well I don't
want to be we've spoken with a bunch of
women on the show before and asked the
same sort of question women who Carly
Fiorina was hitting this chair a few
weeks ago and she was talking about some
of her experiences in the business world
with this sort of sexism and I asked her
so how do you deal with the the person
across from you do you seek to diffuse
do you seek to elevate you at what point
do you say okay well I can't work here
anymore how do you draw those lines
yeah and that that's so frustrating to
me as a woman because you feel like you
shouldn't have to make that decision I
mean you shouldn't be put in that place
but also if you're being realistic about
some conditions and I think listen the
last five years or so that's why
we changed that companies are having
extreme makeovers with the way that they
handle HR giving women in a place to
report and so I think there's been such
a disinfectant of sunlight which is
fantastic for all women and men get
harassed to I mean we have to be honest
I've seen those cases plenty of them in
my career as well so I think that the
more we can decide personally where
we're gonna draw a line for me it was
you know I talked about Roger Ailes in
the book and the fact that he was a
dichotomy like everybody he was
incredibly generous to people who were
in trouble or ill or had emergencies in
their life he was a TV genius but there
was the sight of him to that for me I
had to deal with some really
uncomfortable conversations and I kept
going back and having those
conversations because it was part of a
regular part of my career to meet with
him and to advocate for myself to take
on new assignments and do things but
there came a point to me where I felt
like there was a moment where he said
let's talk about you having a show and I
thought fantastic I talked about the
book how I put together this folder of
all of my ideas
it was very mapped out and specific and
I went in there to talk to him I had the
folder he immediately kind of tossed the
folder aside where I realized we're not
gonna have a conversation about this
show that's drawing me back into another
one of these uncomfortable conversations
with him and I said it may jettison my
career but at this point I have to draw
the line here and say I'm not gonna have
these uncomfortable meetings with him
anymore and so for the last two years he
was at Fox I never saw him again in
person and I thought I can live with
that because for me it's gone to my my
breaking point which is no more of this
and I love my job as a Supreme Court
correspondent if that's the last thing I
do at Fox I will have been blessed and I
love it and I left it there and I never
saw him again after that last meeting
where for me that was the line in the
sand I mean I don't mean to get gossipy
but I think I'd be remiss if I didn't
ask what those uncomfortable
conversations were like what what
exactly the content of those was well he
would talk about the need to be more
sexy on TV to the conversation he would
use is people need to think if they went
on a date with you it'd be a good time
because right now that's not the vibe
I'm getting from you I'm kind of getting
like church lady vibe which is me I kind
of give off a church lady vibe but I'm
gonna play with that and I think he
understood the medium of television and
he knew what audiences wanted in a way
that sometimes you had to think okay as
a journalist am i okay with this yes I
can dress differently than when I was a
lawyer and I wear a black suit to court
every day
so okay that's the stuff I can take I
need to dress more colorfully I need to
be more imaginative about that um but if
I have to try to do the news in a way
that's also me flirting with the
audience no that's not okay with me that
feels you can have a wink and a nod
about a funny topic or story here and
there but I didn't want to come across
as provocative or somebody who was
trying to be sexually alluring while
delivering the news that just wasn't
something that works for me as a
combination it's been really fascinating
to watch everybody trying to navigate
kind of the new lines and I'm you know
as a social conservative and somebody
who is very strict on these matters
myself I'm pretty comfortable there's a
social conservative a lot of the new
lines that are being drawn at the same
time one of the things that I see is
that there's almost a virtue that is
attached to claiming for some people
that they've been victimized more than
they've been victimized yeah the other
week I was I was with my wife and we
were at Disneyland with my kids we're
walking down the street and there was
this big fat homeless guy who's sitting
on the side of the street and he's
wearing a beanie with a marijuana symbol
on it I figured okay well this guy
probably is not you know vice-president
at Chase Manhattan Bank and we're
walking by and he turns to my wife who's
an attractive woman and as she walks by
he goes oh girl don't do that and my
wife turns to me and she goes still got
it you know I understand the guy come on
like yeah I mean I agree with you I had
a guy on the Metro in DC offered to pay
my rent I was like I haven't heard that
one before but does that apply to
mortgages because like like I'm never
gonna be offended and I won't get emails
from people even friends or people that
I don't know who will say like I love
that dress you had on tonight you look
really great am I getting in trouble for
saying that I'm not one of those people
who cares about that yeah I would like
to think at almost 50 that people would
think I look sort of cute so I'm fine
with that
and if somebody walking down the street
is you know you know it's salacious is
another thing but to get an admiring
glance or something like that I don't
know what woman well no some women will
be offended by that I'm not one of them
I mean sure if it crosses a line into
something super sexual not okay but for
me that even I have male friends that
have to worry about whether they can say
that something looks nice or how I feel
I you know I'm hoping that the pendulum
will equalize somewhere where people can
feel comfortable saying nice things to a
friend or a woman that's in their life
that they are in acquaintance with and
not
feeling like they have to be
hypersensitive but good for your wife so
you have obviously a very demanding
career you also have a family how do you
balance the needs that mean you're doing
a show at 11:00 p.m. on the East Coast
that's that's really rough my wife has
bad hours because she's a doctor
but you know eventually that will end
and she'll finish residency and she'll
choose her own hours how do you have
been able to balance those demands well
I'm an idol so that for me works really
well I was for about a year doing the
morning show with Bill Hemmer who I
adore in New York that meant I was up at
4:30 which those are not my hours am
4:30 I'm sure so when they came to me
and said we really want you to launch
this nighttime news show at 11:00 I
thought I'm awake then that's great for
me so it works really well for me just
you know biologically and I also have a
husband that I've been married for we've
been married for almost 24 years and so
he's been through everything with me to
doing the law and hating it every day of
my life getting up as I'm sure your wife
saw with you going to do it
getting fired moving around the country
I mean I couldn't have done any of this
without him and so we don't have kids
and I talked about that in the book
because I get asked that question a lot
so I explained it in the book but the
two of us you know we kind of try to be
each other's biggest cheerleaders and
biggest supporters we disagree and have
arguments like everybody does but we try
to remember we're on the same team and
so that means that sometimes when I have
crazy hours and I travel he comes with
me when he can where he makes sure that
our house does not completely implode
and disaster when I'm not there you know
he's a guy who's great at you know all
things that I'm not good at which are
like cooking grocery shopping you know
laundry I can put it in there you know
and get it started but but we're very
much a team and I don't think I could
have done any of this without him how
did you meet we met in school at Liberty
University undergrad we had friends were
constantly trying to put us together
we're always dating other people not
that I did anyone before him but
hypothetically but he had friends kept
trying to put us together and so finally
our senior year we were at this
homecoming sort of football game my
parents were there he was there my my
friend who really was instrumental in
putting us together came to me and she's
like you are meeting him today so she
dragged him over to me I think and I was
with my family and I I joke about it I
love my mom and stepdad myself it's very
unique his name is Jasper and so when my
husband I met him that day formally and
we had friends and
but to really meet him I'm staying there
with my stepdad who is a unique
character and I'm thinking he's already
met my very interesting stepdad on day
one of this not even being on a date yet
and so I thought if if he can make it
through that gauntlet on this very first
meeting there might be something to it
now we were still dating other people at
that time so nothing came of it we're at
our final semester in school we were
both single and available and I at that
point in determined I'm leaving I know
I'm going home to law school I'm tired
of having my heart broken by the last
guy that I dated I'm just gonna date
like a guy and I'm not gonna get
emotionally attached maybe a nice dinner
out something like that that's it and he
played baseball and a lot of the players
on the team kind of had this player
reputation for not being the most
wholesome guys in the world they caught
a couple of them rightfully earned but
what I found our first date with him is
that it wasn't accurate for him
and he turned out to be this guy of deep
faith wonderful family background very
family-oriented and I kind of knew very
early on like this guy as marriage
material this is a serious thing I'm
going off to law school what do I do and
I think when you fall in love with
somebody you really can't help that he
says he went home that night after a
first date and told his roommates we
were gonna get married
he didn't tell me that for a little
while but I think that I knew right away
it was something different - yeah that
is every story that I hear is basically
the guy knows almost immediately and
then it's at least this is what was with
my wife as well I knew like right away
that I was gonna marry my wife and then
it took her a little while longer yeah
exactly I every so often I look at her
and I'll say yeah that's right
eventually you came around her over yeah
exactly so I mean we have two kids now
so it's too late it's right out she
can't get out or at 11 years in July so
that she can't gap so you open your book
talking about this health crisis that
you had with your sight and how your
faith helped get you through I was
wondering you tell that story
yeah I've been struggling for a long
time with a genetic eye condition that I
have and I didn't know I mean it took me
almost two years to actually get
diagnosed what I knew was I started
waking up in the middle of the night
with excruciating pain that I mean
literally makes me jump out of bed I
mean it was as if somebody were stabbing
my eye it seems so strange when it first
started happening because it was very
infrequent became more and more frequent
my first original eye doctor was like I
can't help you but I think we need to
get you to a specialist to figure this
out I went to that next specialist spend
a few months with him it got to the
point where is nearly every
night so I dreaded going to sleep
because I knew for whatever reason this
was happening overnight so I'm exhausted
I'm now living in chronic pain double
vision a lot migraines everything that
was triggered by what was happening with
my eyes trying to hide it from everybody
and do my job because I had no words for
it I had no diagnosis so after a couple
of visits to this specialist I went back
to him and I was really just barely
holding it together at this point I'm
like 18 months into not sleeping chronic
pain and he says to me you know I just
think you're really emotional and I
thought yeah I am because my world is
like I'm barely holding it together at
this point I left there and felt so
discouraged that he couldn't help me and
that it was sort of suggested that I was
nuts
that for a long time I didn't go back to
the doctor so I'm living in this
constant cycle of excruciating pain
chronic sleep deprivation and that gets
you to a really bad place because I'm
now almost two years into it start
searching online which I say don't do
for health condition because you'll find
out you like 17 seconds to live and
that's it it's all over so I was just
trying to find people with similar
symptoms so I could get an answer and I
would stumble into these message boards
and chat boards what other people would
say yeah I've been turned away from the
emergency room ten times nobody can tell
me no one can help me and they you know
would talk about ending their lives and
I thought actually sounds like a huge
relief I'd gotten to the point where I
was into my 40s then and I thought I
can't make it another 40 years like this
I can't make it 40 seconds some days I
barely able to keep it together and I
thought that just sounds like such a
relief I could just go to sleep and not
wake up and I really started to think it
through a little bit what would it do to
my family what would it do to the people
that I loved and that sort of shocked me
a little bit too logically and
intellectually knowing that's not the
choice you want to make but it was in
such a bad state emotionally and I think
when you're physically exhausted too it
exacerbates everything and I went to my
husband and said listen I'm really at
the lowest point and he was the only one
who had any clue what was happening and
he said we're gonna find you a doctor
we're gonna start from scratch we're
gonna do this and I remember praying so
many times lord if you're not gonna heal
me please just send me to the right
person who can help me cuz sometimes God
has a different plan that we do and I
thought maybe not healing me that's not
part of it so I worked to find another
doctor within a couple of days I found
this fantastic cornea specialist in DC
and I called and I said keep it
crazy don't cry on this phone call and
the lady said to me can you hold on she
came back and said he had a cancellation
for tomorrow can you make it and I said
I just one more night god I'm just
praying get me through this night let
this guy help me tomorrow I get there
and his assistant who does the initial
assessment does all the write-up he
walks in having read that he's like I
know what you have in it really for the
first time in two years I felt like this
little sprout of Hope like somebody
finally is gonna help me he says let me
look at your eyes but I'm almost 100%
sure he goes through and he's like yep
this is what you have it's a genetic
condition as we go through the
appointment he eventually says to me
just so you know there's no cure and I
completely lost it I don't remember even
checking out I remember running back to
my car I was filling in for Brett Barry
that night on the six o'clock show I had
to get back and I remember getting in
the car and just sobbing and sobbing and
sobbing and saying like God why like
there I can't continue living like this
and I really just thought I'm gonna
strive my car for bridge I mean I can't
function this way anymore
and I was praying and crying and I
remember I say to people I don't feel
like I ought ibly heard the voice of God
but I remember feeling in my spirit him
saying I will be with you not I'm gonna
heal you I'm gonna take this away life's
gonna be perfect but I'm gonna walk
through this with you and it was such a
calming thing because it felt like I
heard from him
and I drove back to work got through
that day eventually went back to the
doctor and he said I don't want you to
miss what I'm saying I can't heal you
there's no cure for this but we can
manage it and eventually years later
what that meant was having the surgery
that I put off and put off and put off
and the prognosis was I'm gonna work on
your corneas do this thing but while I'm
there I'm gonna correct your vision as
well it's the same time I'm launching
this new 11 o'clock show for Fox and I'm
like great I have a couple weeks
off-camera he says within a couple weeks
most patients have their vision better
than it's ever been it's gonna be great
I quickly realize first of all it was an
excruciating pain for the recovery it's
just part of it but I couldn't see I
mean I could see blobs I couldn't drive
I couldn't read my phone I couldn't read
my computer I couldn't recognize
people's faces I completely shut down
and kind of went into a show because I
thought I can't even say hi to people in
the hall cuz they're blobs walking by I
don't know who this is so I talked about
in the book during that I had been
booked to speak at a conference a
Christian conference and I wanted to
cancel because I thought this is
ridiculous I can't even I don't know how
am I gonna get there I can't see
and so I went to my husband looking for
affirmation of wanting to cancel this
thing but I didn't get that from him and
he said nope I think you should go I
think you should be honest these are
people of faith and they're gonna want
to hear this and be supportive of you
and he was right just navigating the
airport I talked about in the book I
mean I couldn't see I'm asking people to
help me to get from gate to gate and I'm
just really emotional about nothing able
to see I go on the stage to speak I
can't see they're like hey just look at
the clock in the back you need to wrap
up at this time and I'm like I can't see
the clock in the back I can't see
people's face in the audience my mom met
me there to be my seeing-eye human for
the weekend to get me through this thing
and I just leveled with people I was
honest in that speech like hey I'm not
here to make fun of myself and be funny
like I usually am like I'm struggling
but I'm hoping that you all will
understand this and I'm relying on God
because I know this purpose and this it
makes you more empathetic when you go
through things like that and he's
teaching me something so I get this
moment that I'm in when it was over
people lined up down the aisles just to
hug me to pray with me to cry with me to
tell me about their own struggles and
say like hey I'm in a terrible place too
and it was a greatest blessing just
being vulnerable and honest with people
about how much I was struggling and I
hadn't looked at it that way but it made
me realize I hate being vulnerable I
want to be independent do everything
myself I came out of the womb that way
but you got to lean on other people
sometimes and if you don't give them the
gift of being honest about how you're
struggling then they don't get the gift
I think of helping you I think that
that's one of the most beautiful things
about the book finding the bright side
is is that you actually do talk about
this sort of stuff because if you happen
to be a strong person it seems like you
seem like congenitally happy person
person who just by nature every time
I've met you you've been upbeat that
people think therefore that you haven't
suffered that you don't have to struggle
with these things the fact that you were
willing to openly struggle with these
things I think is a good reminder to
folks that just because somebody is
happy doesn't mean that they're not
struggling to be happy or that if you
have struggles you can't be happy yeah
and that's what I hope people will be
encouraged in it because everybody if
you haven't been there you'll be there
a sudden death of someone you love a
terrible health diagnosis losing your
job financial trouble just struggles in
relationships whatever it is we're all
gonna be in a valley at some point and
because people do think I'm so happy all
the time I thought it was important to
tell some really tough stories in the
book and say I've been in that valley
there are ways to work through it you
will come out the other side life
doesn't always go as we planned there's
plenty of pain in the process but
I think there's purpose in it I'm Way
more empathetic to people now living
with chronic pain or mental health
issues cuz I've been there
I think it makes you look at different
people differently like you have no idea
what's going on with them I remember at
one point being on a treadmill and
running and thinking like yeah I'm
barely I could burst into tears at any
moment do all these things I'm
struggling with person next to me has no
idea what if that person feels the same
way the person who cut me off in traffic
which I hate I'm a little crazy but I
feel real myself but who knows what
they're rushing off to do I mean we have
to give each other a little bit more
leeway and a little bit more respect and
love because everybody's struggling with
something so let's get back to you you
covering stories and journalism so you
talked about the difficulties of
covering the Cavanaugh hearings what was
the hardest story you had to cover and
what hardest for you personally um
I think sometimes where you've been at
the site of devastation I mean I've
covered tornadoes and you know storm
superstorm sandy things like that where
you see people who are utterly feel like
they've lost everything or they're just
looking around themselves in their life
at least the physical part of their life
seems to be in shambles I mean that's
really difficult I had a story one time
when I was a local reporter in DC about
a woman who had been out walking an
older woman and she had been there was a
hit-and-run and police were searching
for this person she had been killed in
that accident and as a reporter you know
you have to go to the family and go
knock on the door I got there and it
became quickly apparent to me as I
started talking to her husband he did
not know yet and we were the first ones
to arrive on the scene his kids weren't
even there yet and those moments make
you stop and think about humanity and
just how precious life is and how people
we can report on these stories every day
people's lives are being devastated by
the things that we report on whether
it's a shooting or anything else a
natural disaster so I think things that
force you back to the humanity of the
people that you're covering so they
aren't just another story that you read
in the prompter but you're actually
seeing them and seeing the devastation
to them I think as a reporter those are
the hardest things to show up and see
people and enormous grief you know it's
interesting being in sort of the
political business and covering the news
every so often I sit around wondering am
I really just sort of in the gossip
business because it seems like a lot of
what we do these days is just covering
whatever gossip is happening without
real really thing about how it impacts
people's lives what what gets you up in
the morning to do what you do for a
living when it seems like you know half
the stuff that we have to cover is just
minutia
or rat of the day I'm super curious you
probably are too you strike me as that
kind of person where I want to know
what's the real story behind the story
so I feel like every day we're going to
have we know what guests we have on we
know certain things that we're covering
I want to get people off their talking
points and find out what's really going
on so much of DC is political theater I
think the best example of that was a few
weeks ago when speaker Pelosi and
Attorney General Barr we're at this
event and behind the scenes they see
each other and he jokes to her about
whether she's brought her handcuffs like
she's gonna throw him in the jail over
at the Capitol and she makes a joke back
well the sergeant-at-arms is here so if
I need to arrest anyone I can that's a
typical DC thing people will be at these
events or cocktail parties and they're
fine but the minute you put them in
front of a camera there's a partisan
agenda and that people have to be mad at
each other were truthfully they're very
chummy a lot of them and when they see
each other socially it's fine so I think
knowing that a lot of this is for show
it's for the rest of us and kind of
digging to see what's really behind it
what the real policy is what the real
motivations are because there's always a
secret motivation behind a lot of these
stories and the reasons that people
introduce a bill or vote for a bill or
don't vote for bill so to me what gets
me up is digging to find the story
behind the actual headline to see what's
really going on in current politicians
forever so does that do you think that
they are more or less honest than they
are portrayed in the media oh I think
that's tough you know my my dad used to
always joke like lawyers are the worst
rated people I think behind dentist as
far as like how the public feels about
them and then there's journalists so
he's like really you're leaving law and
journalists people feel this way about
politicians um I think that what's so
funny is you always see the approval
rating for Congress is like 18 percent
or something like that but when you ask
people about their member it's way
higher so I think they're frustrated
with the institution and see that it's
paralyzed and doesn't get a lot done but
when you talk to them about the person
that represents them a lot of times
alike well that's different
my person is different and I think we've
talked about this a lot of politicians
away from the camera are great people
that you'd want to hang out and go to
lunch with them or hang out with their
families but I think something happens
sometimes in front of the cameras they
feel an obligation to have a certain
talking pointer to be a certain way I do
think there are good people on both
sides of the aisle who generally are
driven by their faith their own moral
compass that they genuinely believe in
and that they want to make a difference
in a positive way I think that's the
minority and
I think a lot of other people are on the
hill for a lot of other reasons or they
go there with good intentions but they
get caught up in the whole thing
I mean I'm personally a fan of the idea
of discussing term limits I think
America should have that conversation
it would require amending the
Constitution which is not easily done
you know so I don't know I think a lot
of people get there and they get
enamored of the whole thing and it's
changes that since we're both members of
the media well how do you think the
media climate has contributed to this so
if it used to be that I've said forever
that people say well if you're a
president what would you do I'd say
basically make it so that I thought Rick
Perry's line was the best make it so
that Washington DC is irrelevant in your
life so you don't care who's the
president you don't care who's in
Congress because they're not bothering
you all the time but the media because
we cover this stuff incessantly because
we're on top of it all the time how much
are we magnifying the the conflict and
making the conflict worse as opposed to
helping to get people behind the news
that they're saying yeah I think
sometimes we have to be very careful not
to take the bait because I think both
sides will put it out there and there's
history Onex about this or that and you
get the press releases or the releases
from the congressional offices or the
tweets they're like this is the end of
the world and you're like no it's not
you guys have voted on this before you
know this is not the end of the world so
I think we tried it like I say when I go
through a script and I see too many
adjectives I want to take those out like
I don't want to be so descriptive and
hyperbolic about things I think that we
have a responsibility to present things
and sometimes if a story has been super
overhyped we're like you know what we're
not doing a full guest segment on that
we're gonna read it and tell people
about it in the story but we're not
devoting five or ten minutes to it
because it's not something that rises to
the level of that in reality and I think
it's up to us to parse the difference so
since now you've been covering a very
polarized period in American history are
you optimistic or pessimistic for where
the country is going I'm always
optimistic you know me I'm very
Pollyanna people will say at times so I
mean there's a great book out a few
years ago called implosion by Joel
Rosenberg it was very interesting
because he talks about times where our
country has seemed irreparably fractured
you think about the civil war and other
periods and it was it was a very good
book for me to go back and read when
things seem so crazy right now to say
like our country has been in horribly
divided places before and we have found
ways he says mostly through religious
revival but we found ways to come back
to our humanity and to each other and
you don't want a tragedy to have to be
the way the country comes back together
but there have been examples through
history where we've been in a much worse
place I mean someone
caning someone to Duff on the Senate
floor essentially I mean it has been
crazier as bad as it may seem now and
we've come back from that we have
reunited many times and I think I'll
always think that there is good ahead so
I do have one final question for I only
asked you you can give three piece of
advice to young up and comers who want
to get into journalism want to get into
covering politics what those would be
but if you actually want to hear Shannon
Bream's answer you have to be a daily
wire subscriber to subscribe head on
over to daily wire comm click subscribe
you can hear the end of our conversation
there now shannon bream thanks so much
for stopping I really appreciate your
book is finding the bright side folks
you go pick it up right now thank you
very much great to be with you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover
edited by Donovan Fowler audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Alvaro title graphics by Cynthia
Angulo the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19